the relationship between the European
Union and China is simultaneously one of
the most strategically important and one
of the most challenging that we have
today summit has been a much needed
opportunity to discuss and move forward
on all aspects of this complex and vital
partnership our discussions were both
intense and they were indeed wide
ranging from trade and investment to
climate action and the digital field
from Hong Kong to Human Rights and of
course the coronavirus response and we
are able to discuss all these issues
with China but I must say mostly
important wasn't is that we must make
progress today has been a very intense a
very frank and a very open meeting we
would want and expect nothing less this
was good it is not possible to shape the
world of tomorrow without a strong EU
China relationship however it is time to
accelerate on the very crucial areas of
our relationship to deliver on the
important commitments from last summit
and address our concerns on reciprocity
and the level playing field as European
Union were committed to making Swift and
substantial progress we count on the
Chinese leadership to match our level of
ambition